future for stage 32 yeah we have so many
plans and you know only so many bodies
to execute him but you know I used to
joke that I used to joke that we wanted
to be home depot for filmmakers and and
now it's becoming much less of a joke
with each passing day we laugh a little
bit less about that because you know we
want to provide every single tool
possible you know for filmmakers from or
all creatives i should say from concept
to completion we used to say but now
we're talking about you know concept of
distribution and beyond and you know we
have a lot of people on this site
creating incredible content and we want
to be able to curate that content and we
want to be able to take our most
respected members as far as their
talents are concern and their work is
concerned and make sure that the
showcase and make sure that they
highlighted and you know we just like i
said we just distributed our first film
online which was cut and we plan on
doing a lot more of that and we have a
lot if you just have a lot of plans in
the future that i think are going to be
really really exciting as we move into
this streaming distributing all these
new outlets and all these new
opportunities we want to be at the
forefront of everything that that's
embodied with them and so stage 32 was
born from you being on a film set and
wanting to connect with people it was it
was born from a lot of different things
like I said the embryonic idea even
though maybe I didn't realize it back
then was my acting days in New York and
seeing so many people leave the game the
the second part was being on the set of
another happy day the film went to
Sundance that you know again we had this
family and then everybody went home and
they were all looking for jobs and very
very talented people and I felt like I
had to be a better way with that and
then the third thing was being at the
american film market purdue we were
there to sell a film and you know i was
watching people come from all over the
world taking their lottery shop more or
less I don't want Chloe watery sharkus I
mean that's actually not unfair because
you know a lot of people came quality
material but a lot of rot every shot in
the sense that this was their week okay
they're going to take you know they
saved up all their money traveled
halfway around the world and now they're
going to try to do this and when I spoke
to people and said what happens if you
don't
you know talking to people from
Australia or people from Japan and
saying what happens if you don't sell
here and they would say well you know
probably come back a year from now and
try again and I said really and the way
what else we supposed to do we have no
other connections there's no other way
to get to people and I said that was the
final straw that I said okay I have to
do this so the idea really I really had
the idea back in like two thousand nine
but it took me two years to convince
myself to actually go do it because I
knew it was going to be a huge
undertaking and a lot of my time and at
the time I was you know writing and
producing so well I still am but I mean
you know I didn't want to pull away from
that but I just felt like it was it was
necessary there was a need and I really
did believe coming from an internet
background having run some businesses in
the internet space prior to all this I
really did feel that niche niche social
networks with the next big thing and
that people that you know we're on broad
based networks are going to be on broad
based networks for friends and family
and not necessarily for their careers
and I think that that's proven to be
true I think that you know most people
use facebook and even Twitter to in a
certain extent to you know for friends
and fishy face but friends and family
but the people you know all these niche
networks have popped up for hobbies and
for specific business and for this
industry there was nothing and you know
stage 32
you